[Musique]
un menu unique et sans viande
c'est ce qui sera proposé aux écoliers
lyonnais à partir de demain et au moins
jusqu'aux vacances de pâques menu unique
ça nous permet de fluidifier le service
de gagner du temps et donc les enfants
peuvent passer sur sur la pause
méridienne peuvent tous passés et tous
manger quand on a ce type d'idées à
prendre et convient les mettre sur le
dos de la commodité alors il faut pas se
demander pourquoi de temps en temps nos
gamins dans ses cantines qui viennent
parfois des quartiers populaires c'est
le cas à lyon comme dans d'autres
territoires sont souvent à l'occasion de
ces repas le seul moment où ils vont
pouvoir manger équilibré la mesure passe
mal également dans le monde agricole
avec des éleveurs qui se sentent à
nouveau visé depuis la fin de matinée
ils manifestent aux abords de l'hôtel de
ville
en plus de l'insultent inacceptable aux
agriculteurs et aux bouchers français on
voit bien que la politique moraliste et
élitiste des verts exclus les classes
populaires
de nombreux enfants n'ont souvent que la
cantine pour manger de la viande je
rappelle que c'était une promesse de
campagne du maire et qui profitent
opportunément de la crise qu vite pour
faire glisser sa promesse de campagne
là moi je raisonne en tant que médecin
nos enfants dans leur assiette ils ont
besoin d'avoir une assiette équilibrée
plutôt qu'une assiette idéologique on a
des protéines animales on va servir du
poisson ou des oeufs au moins ça c'est
de la politique la polémique
politicienne c'est tout alors ça vient
là du gouvernement mais quel intérêt
mais il ya un ministre des cantines
scolaires maintenant j'ai pas été mis au
courant
arrêtons de mettre de l'idéologie dans
l'assiette de nos enfants donnons-leur
simplement ce dont ils ont besoin pour
bien grandir la viande en fait partie
j'ai saisi le préfet du rhône
pourquoi s'énerver maintenant déjà le
menu unique il a été appliqué à lyon
sans faire scandale lors du premier
confinement d'abord pour les enfants de
soignants et puis vraiment pour tous à 7
entre mai et juillet 2020 qu'est ce qui
a changé depuis pas le maire pour nous
nous étions dans une situation qui était
extrêmement différente puisque les
élèves revenaient
après un confinement que nous avions
d'ailleurs la moitié des élèves qui
revenait et donc ne nous savions pas
c'est effectivement il manger de la
viande pas de viande etc
maintenant on a le recul nécessaire la
situation épidémique actuel impose
également une restriction des
déplacements et donc un confinement
partiel ma conviction profonde et qu'on
va vers le bout du tunnel
d'autres mesures sont décrété la
fermeture des commerces et galerie
marchande de plus de 5000 m² sauf les
commerces alimentaires dans les
commerces de plus de 400 mètres carrés
la jauge passe de dix à quinze mètres
carrés par client alors vont-ils
remporté leur pari ce que ça fonctionne
oui deux vidéastes mcfly et carlito bien
connu s'ils atteignent les 10 millions
de vues ils pourront soumettre à
emmanuel macron emmanuel macron un
concours d'anecdotes c'est un format qui
connut sur leur chaîne aujourd'hui 5,6
millions de vues en moins de 24 heures
alors il y en a c'est le fils de guy
carlier
oui mais alors il s'appelle david koskas
et raphaël carlier effectivement ils
sont tous les deux ils ont 34 ans et pas
des petits jeunes à certains musées
d'ailleurs évoqué la possible date du 8
mars est ce que ça cela vous semble que
je ne suis pas venu je suis désolé je ne
suis pas venu là pour vous donner une
date qui n'est pas encore fixée
facebook qui bloquent des messages de
marion maréchal et de jordan barre dès
lors d'un hiver l'ancien député fn et le
vice président du rassemblement national
ont découvert que plusieurs de leur
publication avait été supprimée raison
de cette suppression des messages de
soutien au mouvement génération
identitaire que facebook sans sur la
page de jordan bardella et celle de
marion maréchal est un signe extrêmement
préoccupant de la montée d'une censure
décomplexé à travers les réseaux sociaux
une censure qui relaie c'est que le
gouvernement lui-même rêve d'organiser
vous mettez pas le président actuel dans
votre mairie vous mettez des anciens
présidents
là c'est uniquement que le président de
la république et son portrait dans la
salle des mariages
d'accord mais dans votre bureau vous
mettez pas les présidents qui l'ont pas
de votre camp c'est ça c'est à peu près
ça